ce que la situation se calme non
s'inventant peut pas vraiment parler
d'accalmie vous le voyez peut-être
derrière moi on a des forces de l'ordre
qui procèdent à de nombreux tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes pour tenter un maximum de
repousser les manifestants pourquoi
repousser les manifestants et bien
puisqu'ils ont réussi justement c'est
certes un élément en tout cas radi quoi
repousser les forces de l'ordre qui
avaient réduit de manière un peu plus
importante
cette place d'aidés des invalides ses
forces de l'ordre ont reculé de
plusieurs un mètre ils se sont elles se
sont montrés un peu plus discrète
pendant un quart d'heure vingt minutes
et elle réplique désormais assez
systématiquement avec un air miles est
la réplique systématiquement à coups de
gaz lacrymogènes des forces de l'ordre
qui avaient un moment procéder à des
arrestations des interpellations ciblées
mais ça a été une mais des méthodes
d'interpellation qui a été impossible à
poursuivre c'était impossible pour les
forces de l'ordre de poursuivre
interpellé de manière plus ciblée c'est
certains éléments radicaux parce que la
réponse
la réponse de ces éléments radicaux et
bien c'est mon très intense plus
importante que ce que je peux vous dire
est bien c'est que on a d'un côté
certains manifestants pacifistes qui
sont désabusés un de voir comment voir
la suite de cette manifestation qui
avait pourtant bien commencé et de
l'autre en face à face assez intenses
entre les forces de l'ordre et plusieurs
plusieurs manifestants et donc voilà on
peut pas parler d'accalmie
de retour au calme ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les forces de l'ordre
sont plus discrètes que tout à l'heure
et qu'elle procède maintenant pour
tenter de repousser les manifestants à
coup de gaz lacrymogène on va peut-être
rejoindre alexandre alexandrie les
techniciens de laboratoire à l'hôpital
beaujon à clichy alexandre dit moi je
vous vois vous ma vie vous me dites vous
êtes un peu désabusé de voir comment se
poursuit cette manifestation qui avait
pourtant bien commencé
aux abords du ministère de la santé
votre réaction
moi ça me rend triste parce qu'en fait
toutes ces personnes ne se rendent pas
compte que ils sont frères il s'agit
aujourd'hui de défendre les valeurs de
l'humanité je pense et ce qui est en
train de se passer là bas c'est triste
moi ça me rend triste
je suis personnel soignant je devais
vous ma vie à une bien que je sois que
technicien de laboratoire
je suis d'abord personnel soignant c'est
à dire je le dis vous pourrez aider les
personnes qui ont besoin quel que soit
leur situation
quelles que soient leurs uniformes voilà
il ya des personnes qui vont être blessé
aujourd'hui elles vont toutes se
retrouver à l'hôpital
et quand elles seront assises ou
allongées les unes à côté des autres
eh bien elles se rendront compte que
d'abord elles sont humaines et c'est ce
manque d'humanité aujourd'hui je pense
moi qui me rend triste et la lutte qu'il
faut mener aujourd'hui c'est retrouver
les liens entre les uns les unes les
autres
au delà des au delà des uniformes au
delà de secours défend on a tous tout
des positions différentes
mais on respire le même air on s'en est
rendu compte avec cette situation
comment un virus a pu d'une part mettre
en évidence la fragilité de notre
humanité en même temps montré que c'est
à travers des valeurs de solidarité que
on va pouvoir se retrouver et une fois
de plus c'est bien la haine reprend
reprend le dessus en quelque sorte
moi ce que je souhaiterais c'est que
évidemment ça fait partie de la réalité
mais peut-être de focaliser un peu plus
sur toutes ces personnes qui elles
restent pacifiques voilà et sont là et
comme moi et bien son triste parce que
parce qu'elles sont venus défendre comme
valeur ben va être salis tout simplement
par des personnes qui sont pas
conscientes de ce qu'elles sont en train
de faire alors il faut il faut que faut
changer là et le temps est venu vraiment
d'un grand changement
et personnellement je vois du fond de
mon coeur pour que ça se fasse de
manière de la manière la plus paisible
possible alors il ya encore du travail
voilà mais je suis absolument convaincu
que si on regarde tous au même endroit
et que l'on cesse de s'unir dans nos
divisions et qu'on retrouve conscience
du fait que ben voilà nous sommes
d'abord des êtres humains quoi l'hôpital
public est malade aujourd'hui pourquoi
est ce que vous avez fait le déplacement
participer à cette grande manifestation
aujourd'hui du 16 juin
parce que l'hôpital aujourd'hui ça
représente le symbole derniers symboles
peut-être de ce que peut être le lien
entre les humains à savoir la vie ou la
mort puisque personnel soignant a
confronté à ça en permanence on se bat
pour sauver des vies et on se rencontre
en fait que dans nos sociétés et bien
que ce soit pour les personnes âgées ou
pour les hôpitaux
alors humaine aujourd'hui disparaissent
parce que voilà une perte de conscience
tout est devenu monnayable comptable
raisonnable donc on cherche simplement à
casser ce qui reste d'humanité de
fraternité et moi je me bats uniquement
pour défendre cette valeur là vous
croyez pas aux ségur de la santé il me
semble que c'est bien mal engagée parce
que c'est dur de la santé va être une
fois de plus une discussion politique
c'est à dire une discussion qui va
d'abord faire appel à des discours et à
des schémas de pensée plutôt que se
retrouver dans le coeur alors que là la
situation mériterait que l'on prenne
conscience de je le redis notre
fragilité ça veut dire que pour ça on
est obligé maintenant de mettre à plat
énormément de choses de retrouver le
lien l'humanité au-delà des difficultés
financières qui sont en fait je pense on
peut les régler voilà la dette de la
france est colossal à vous pensez qu'il
est qu'on peut trouver de l'argent pour
l'hopital faut trouver alors la dette ça
n'existe pas voyez demain vous allez
voir un banquier il va l'ouvrir une
ligne il va mettre cent mille euros
dessus cet argent n'existe pas à la
dette c'est le plus grand mensonge la
plus grande manipulation qui a été mise
en place depuis les années 70 la dette
c'est simple les 20 personnes les plus
puissantes du monde se réunissent autour
d'une table et décide de remettre les
compteurs à zéro et et on repartirait
sur des valeurs qui seraient des valeurs
réaliste et plus basée sur des mensonges
financier calculateur on s'est bien fait
avoir dans cette histoire
personnellement
réveil a été douloureux quand j'ai
compris ça mais maintenant c'est une
réalité
donc il faut défendre ça alexandre merci
pour ce témoignage rappelle que vous
êtes technicien de laboratoire à
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy merci et
merci beaucoup donc au vous avez entendu
cette colère et cette déception de ce
technicien de laboratoire qui estime
qu'aujourd'hui c'était le jour le jour
où il fallait montrer bien justement que
le personnel hospitalier étaient
mobilisés pour demander pacifiquement
plus de moyens pour l'hôpital public
un technicien de laboratoire qui comme
beaucoup d'autres manifestants et s'il
s'est montré déçu de la suite des
événements une manifestation qui a donc
dégénéré ici place des invalides avec
des affrontements assez récurrent entre
forces de l'ordre et incertain certains
éléments cagoulés et habillés de noir
notamment
merci beaucoup nadège abderrazak